we're learning more tonight about why
the jury and the Paul Manafort trial had
so much trouble reaching verdicts on
more than half of the counts against him
correspondent Peter Doocy has the
behind-the-scenes information from one
of the jurors for 16 days 54 year old
Paula Duncan was juror 0 3 0 2 filling a
pair of marble notebooks with detailed
observations of every argument she voted
for Trump in 2016 and she also voted to
convict his former campaign chairman
Paul manna for fine mr. mana for guilty
was hard for me I wanted him to be
innocent I really wanted him to be
innocent but he was it this week mana
fort was convicted on eight counts of
tax and bank fraud and the judge
declared mistrials on ten other counts
where the jury couldn't come to a
consensus but now we know they came
really close it would have been guilty
on all 18 counts if not for the one
email that said she had reasonable doubt
this jurors doubts appear to be geared
more towards the motives of the Muller
team it's a witch-hunt to try to find
the Russian collusion and pin it on
president Trump Duncan had a head-on
view of the Muller team from the jury
box and said sometimes the prosecutors
had heavy eyelids a lot of times they
looked bored and other times they
catnapped
Duncan sympathized with the defense
team's argument that all these
allegations could have been settled with
an audit but she contends mana fort was
charged because he once worked for the
president he wouldn't have gotten caught
if they weren't after President Trump
still the special counsels prosecutors
overwhelmed Duncan and the other jurors
with evidence the paper trail was just
there was so much of it there were four
full boxes of papers to go through those
papers were apparently a lot more
compelling than the Muller team's star
witness Ric gates whose so-called secret
life was exposed on the stand I think he
deserves a special place in hell he was
just as guilty as Paul Manafort maybe
even more I mean he embezzled from his
employer in the jury room Duncan says
tempers flared during the four day long
deliberations there's no tears and being
a juror but there were one juror mouthed
off about the mana fork team which led
to sealed talks about a mistrial
released transcripts revealed the judge
learned that a mystery juror quote made
it very clear that she didn't feel that
the defense really had anything to offer
up coming in for the rest of the trial
the defense then pushed for a mistrial
arguing quote we would obviously not
agree that that's a small thing when a
juror in the middle of a trial or over a
four or five day period we have jurors
making comments on the weakness of the
defense but Judge Ellis said I see no
earthly reason for a mistrial judge
Ellis later kept the names of the jurors
under seal citing threats he'd received
but Duncan doesn't sense any danger I'm
not concerned had the verdict gone any
other way I might have been one thing
that hasn't changed
Paula Duncan's devotion to Trump which
was on display on her way to court every
day when I drove I had my make America
great again hat in the backseat just as
a reminder judge Ellis said that
publicly sharing details of
deliberations could cause injury to the
deliberative process but he told jurors
they could do whatever they want and
Paula Duncan insists that she did what
she was told and always kept an open
mind even though she did have a make
America great again hat in the parking
garage here at the courthouse
Brett produced the outside of the
courthouse tonight Peter thank you